[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so vieles was
heute gibt es endlich ein paar
informationen über meine eigene
fernsehsendung vor ein paar wochen habe
ich bereits ein video hochgeladen und
habe ich erzählt dass es in diesem jahr
soweit ist ich werde meine eigene
fernsehsendung produzieren
zu hause in waghäusel mit meinem eigenen
team und ich bin muss ich echt zu geben
ein bisschen aufgeregt und ich freue
mich natürlich schon sehr und ich habe
euch auch schon erzählt dass auch ihr
eine große rolle spielt und zwar dürft
ihr euch bewerben wenn ihr zwischen 8
und 18 jahre alt seid und jemandem eine
richtig große freude machen möchte
bei mir war es zum beispiel so meine
eltern die haben mich mein ganzes leben
lang schon unterstützt sie haben mich
während der schulzeit unterstützt
während im studium finanziert sie haben
während dem studium auch mal die samira
zum babysitten genommen damit ich
wirklich in ruhe studieren konnte jetzt
beim bau unterstützt mich mein papa ganz
arg und hilft uns immer wo er nur kann
und es einfach immer für uns da also
meinen eltern das sind wirklich gold
schätze und ich hoffe dass wir noch ganz
ganz lange gesund bleiben und mir noch
ganz ganz viel freude bereiten werden
und meine eltern werde einfach die zwei
personen denen ich meinen größten dank
zurückgeben möchte und die ich wirklich
einfach glücklich machen wollen würde
und natürlich auch jedes mal mache und
ja wenn ihr auch so eine person habt die
ihr gerne glücklich machen möchtet dann
dürft ihr euch gerne bei mir bewerben
für die fernsehsendung und zwei werden
wir zwei du und ich dann gemeinsam eine
torte backen für die person die torte
das wird dann natürlich eine richtig
tolle motiv torte die wir gemeinsam
gestalten und dafür muss ich natürlich
erst einmal im vornherein wissen wer
bist du
das heißt du kannst dich dann in einem
video kurz vorstellen wie gesagt
zwischen 8 und 18 jahre alt sein
ich brauche natürlich dafür auch die
einverständniserklärung der eltern und
dann darfst du mir gerne erzählen was
verbindet sich dann mit der person wer
ist diese person und warum hat diese
person eine torte verdient und dann
würde ich doch gerne wissen was zeichnet
denn diese person aus ist es vielleicht
ein opa oder deine tante es kann aber
auch zum beispiel eine lehrerin sein
didier supertolles englisch beigebracht
hat vielleicht ist es auch eine
nachbarin die dir immer den hund abnimmt
oder auch mal mit dem hund gassi geht
wenn du nicht zu hause bist und es
werden einfach informationen die ich
benötige
wenn ich mir eine richtig tolle tore
dazu ausdenken kann und dann mit dir
zusammen gestalten kann
wichtig wäre auch zu wissen was für eine
geschmacksrichtung wünschst du dir zum
beispiel oder darfst einfach so ein
bisschen die auch überlegen was könnten
wir dann zusammen machen vielleicht hast
du auch eigene ideen und wünsche und
dann können wir zwei kreativ werden und
hier hinter wir in dieser küche die du
wahrscheinlich von meinen youtube-videos
schon kämpft einfach zusammen richtig
tolle torte backen
ich glaube das ganze wird richtig toll
vor allem kann man zum beispiel wenn der
opa feuerwehrmann ist können wir
zusammen eine feuerwehr torte backen
oder wenn deine mama die person ist der
duh eine freude machen möchte ist und
sie blumen über alles liebt können wir
eine torte mit ganz ganz vielen blumen
gestalten
und ja da gibt es ja wirklich also der
kreativität ist keine grenzen gesetzt
wir können alles schaffen was wir zwei
gemeinsam wollen und ich freue mich
wirklich schon sehr darauf dich
kennenzulernen und vor allem mit dir
gemeinsam die torte zu backen
ich wollte die fernsehsendung eigentlich
schon in unseren neuen räumen also in
unserem neuen haus drehen
allerdings ist das natürlich noch nicht
fertig deswegen werden wir hinten in der
küche filme von daher möchte ich gerne
von dir wissen werde ich begleitet also
du darfst eine person mitnehmen also
erziehungsberechtigten zb und da
begleitet dich dann hier zum dreh wir
haben hier natürlich auch unterkunft und
so weiter alles schon bereit
deine geschichte und die geschichte von
der person der die freude machen
möchtest kannst du dann einfach als
bewerbungsvideo an mich schicken und
zwar an diese e mail adresse
und dann ist noch ganz wichtig ich
brauche die kontaktdaten von dir seinen
vollständigen namen und natürlich auch
die einverständniserklärung der eltern
und ihr könnt euch auch ganz viele
informationen und alles weitere was er
noch benötigt einfach unter diese e mail
adresse anschauen euch die
einverständniserklärung herunterladen
und mir dann einfach eine e-mail
schicken
und ich würde am liebsten natürlich alle
von euch mit dem die sendung einladen
und hierher in die küche einladen aber
natürlich muss ich mich auf dem papier
grenzen
deswegen erzähle eine geschichte so
spannend wie möglich und ich bin
wirklich schon gespannt was für
einwendungen kommen werden und wenig
alles kennenlernen darf
und ja ich muss echt sagen wir sind alle
schon ein bisschen aufgeregt der
torhüter der kamera und auch aufgeregt
ja und wir freuen uns alle schon sehr
oft dann nehme ich mein gesamtes team
kennenlernen
und auch den murat den manche vielleicht
nur fromm hinter der kamera kennen ja
was gibt es noch zu sagen ich glaube ich
habe alles gesagt und freue mich auf
euch freue mich auf die einsendungen
einsendeschluss ist übrigens der erste
oktober denn ende oktober mitte oktober
geht's schon mit der produktion los von
daher müssen wir uns jetzt alle sputen
und ich warte auf eure einsendungen also
legt am besten heute schon los schreibt
mir eine e-mail und schickt mir euer
bewerbungsvideo also bis bald ich freue
mich drauf und ja bis zur nächsten wahl